chers amis je vous apporte ce que vous
attendiez avec impatience
savez vous êtes gentil monsieur
distincts mais je l'attendais rien mais
comment ces monsieurs beauchesne tu m'as
dit nous apporter ce paquet c'est
peut-être un cadeau que nous dit
regardez au dirlo des lumières quelle
bonne idée
c'est merveilleux je vais les mettre
tous de mon casque sommes pour une fête
foraine
après tout l'îlot z'enfants c'est une
grande crêpe alors il faut des lumières
ma chère amie s'est positivement
merveilleux vous allez être notre soleil
à nous tous on puisse apporter ma
modeste contribution au mais je vous en
prie messieurs dit cela très bien je
vais mettre mon go on les armoires
d'australie là c'est pas mais s'il me
sens plus en sécurité
eh bien chers amis plus vers moi lien
trou l'a très bien plus haut là c'est
parfait et très bien à votre droite sera
mis à votre droite l'a très bien me
touche et a plus rien c'est parfait
comme ça
maintenant il ne me reste plus qu'à
brancher a pris ma chère amie si vous
permettez en tant que président en
afrique à vous donner
merci chers amis voilà merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
voilà qui vient de condamner doit faire
attention mais c'est très dangereux une
prise de courant
je vais me rendre compte merci en froid
quel choc
je me suis dit sam hamad au musée la
voie là dessus du snow vie il faut faire
très attention une prise de courant il
faut pas mettre ses doigts n'importe où
il faut vérité l'état de cette prise et
puis tenez vous aviez une main nue vous
n'étiez pas protégés par votre gant
donné la loi je vais la mettre moi-même
voici le trio était pas vos doigts
dedans et ça marche oh que c'est beau en
france judicieuse une très bonne idée
c'est monsieur brochet aujourd'hui que
nous pourrions aller tous leurs remercié
mme acharnée pour ma part je me suis
bien d'accord mais aussi profitons du
fait qu'il y ait pas trop de clients
pour lui rendre une petite visite traque
d'accord moi je débranche laprise et
allons-y parfait et réduire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à ces mots c'est moche elle est un vieux
monsieur très sympathique
j'avais vu comme il était heureux de
nous voir c'est vrai et moi je suis très
content d'avoir fait cette jolie
promenade en votre compagnie monsieur a
plaisir à mach vous laisse je retourne à
mon pias a plus tard julie a mais
regardez je rêve que voyez vous m mais
votre guirlandes chers amis et bien sa
guirlande mais n'y a plus dans pool omis
c'est vrai qui a fait ça
attaquants possible mais un voleur dans
l'île aux enfants un voleur ducroix
attendez moi là je reviens tout de suite
je vais me déguiser en ernotte seule
baisse je me demande bien ce qui a pu se
passer qu'à lille céramique en ligne
toutes les cinq minutes passaient que
c'est extraordinaire
enfin un feu ardent poule ça n'existe
pas remarquez c'est peut être un
collectionneur
regardez monsieur christophe casimir il
n'y a aucun doute cette couleur cette
position de casimir eu dans l'effort
cela peut être que lui et ses amis
assez pour casimir us qui dort c'est
calme c'est doux c'est agréable
voici le détective il va certainement
nous aider à résoudre le problème des
ampoules qui ont disparu alors les
effets à la demoiselle geniez bonjour
monsieur mai à l'appel de monsieur
disney
si vous me connaissez vieux sûr puisque
je suis ne le creux le plus grand
détective de tous les cas j'ai donc
compris tout de suite que vous étiez
monsieur 10,9 au le plus noble de tous
les cygnes âge il est formidable
et bien voilà reçu que je le pensais je
sais que toutes les ampoules de toutes
couleurs un disparu et que casimir d'or
avec ses petits poings fun au quel style
pour poursuivre mon enquête
il faut réveiller quelle limite il vit
vous savez bien qu'on ne peut pas
réveiller je sais il ne faut jamais
jamais réveillé un casimir us qui dort
avec ses petits poings fermés
oh quelle finesse quelle intelligence
merci mais hélas pour la première fois
de ma vie je ne vais pas poursuivre
notre quête aux déceptions
j'ai bien dormir mais qu'est-ce que ça
mais c'est nous casimir et monsieur marc
lawrence mais nous sommes alarmés qu'en
fait vous l'a accueilli à lui avant dans
l'île
hélas monsieur casino une femme née les
électriques en poules de sept matches et
le petit génie qu'est ce que c'est que
ça d'un dea en poulain au monsieur
ennjimi qu'elles grimpent les i vous
faites à moi votre ignorance voulzy
naissante
vous n'êtes pas le voleur électrique un
peu avec casimir salade et bord j'avoue
d'éclat et non merci merci monsieur
falaise mais excusez moi j'ai quelque
chose d'important à dire à julie
[Musique]
mais excusez nous deux minutes monsieur
merde au fatah
alors tu écoutes renvoie la jolie je
voulais te dire j'ai goûté les gros
bonbon de toutes les couleurs quand tu a
accroché à conclure ce qu ils sont très
craquant mais ils n'ont pas tous le goût
de fruit et casimir tu as mangé mes
ampoules électriques
[Musique]